domanda ragazzi che mi viene così è
don't wait dragan non svegliare il drago
fatemi capire sotto l'effetto di quelli
droghe stavi quando hai creato sto
livello optimus boy 19 no voglio che è
successo ma stai calmo calmo e vi posso
stare calmo nella vita che succede
perché ce l'hanno bocciata al cesso
mi sono appena [ __ ] drago
[Musica]
va bene perfetto che poi tra l'altro il
drago più in hd che io abbia mai visto
questo sarebbe il drago ma mi svegliate
ragazzi come faccio a farlo posto
livello che il tipo è impossibile da
superare scusatemi ce la faccio non ce
l'ho fatta e impossibile se non lo puoi
superare il suo coso nonno da mina mano
ti prego ma [ __ ]
dai non ci voglio credere mai nella vita
ma com'è possibile che culo che culo va
bene adesso la [ __ ] sarà i miei piedi
sono convinto adesso esco di casa c'è
megan fox che che mi aspetta perché mi
dice ah bravo che è finito il livello di
happy meals sono convintissimo avrà
ragazzi partiamo costo vivo con una
intro decente che meglio degli attriti
ragazzi e benvenuti che sono video sono
lo sveglia draghi della domenica non
seriamente una cosa che non ho capito
vorrei oggi siamo su happy vista ancora
non ho capito com'è possibile che quello
sia considerato un drago perché proprio
non è così che se starò a une boltro e
contrario a che figata original
impossible che tanto stanno finendo le
palle kit e nello stesso punto frase
bruttissima da diretta sono morto
cammino tempo si come fa la palla ad
arrivare alla vittoria non si può fare è
assurdo dove sto mandando a [ __ ]
manon e cannone
[Musica]
grazie creating finish line la fine la
fina e creativa va bene fatemi vedere
giusto e classic straight mi fai un
traguardo diverso in base a quello che
scelgo la vita non è che mi cambia e
credimi dice veramente visto
personalizzandola cosa finale per una
bella
la mia vita adesso sì che completa babbo
svegliato altro giorno ha detto cazzo
perché non mi fanno personalizzare il
finale di happy finalmente l'hanno fatto
dopo chiamo mia mamma al telefono che
sarà sicuramente contenta di sentirlo
l'epicità
[Musica]
sono riuscito a toccare un traguardo e
ciò anche lasciato la testa tra l'altro
prove wall spring off
mi sembra carino dal nome poi non so
magari fa cagare infatti fa cagare mista
sparami veloce salve oddio come l'ho
preso come l'ho preso
ragazzi il finale della vita questo è
stato veramente il finale della vita
nova bene quello che dico no pro ii
clicco ci sono un [ __ ] genio perfetto
perfetto vai vai è saltato liuc è
saltato agli occhi chi se ne frega se ne
frega senza l'aggravante scatenato sto
tizio non ho capito più un cazzo un
certo punto va bene se voi avete capito
qualcosa sono contento per voi io non ho
capito niente core things like soldi non
lo capisco no dai ti prego sti livelli
mi mettono nancy incredibile però sono
vivo come adesso faccio essere vivo cioè
assurdo veramente
l'altro sono atterrato su un arpione ma
va bene no vabbè ragazzi non so perché
mai stai bisogno sto riuscendo a fare
tutto night bike club
se fosse stato nightclub bike sarei
andato al nightclub con la bici non ho
capito cosa stia facendo
ma perché tra tutti quanti io sono
l'unico stronzo ad avere un bambino
cosa fa nono ciak ma tu che cazzo
succede nonno senti tieniti mio figlio
che una persona ecco perfetto che tanto
è inutile non sanno cosa sta facendo
questo davanti a me ma siete scemi
cosa fate cosa fa non fatevi bastare ok
perfetto rye lye veloce veloce back flip
all madonna fenomeno è altro che
nightclub di ddb ci ho messo bene bene
al culo allora io non faccio l'amore io
scopo forte però non così tanto forte lo
ritrova facevano solo trota li ho fatti
tutti i tipi di livelli in solo episodio
di s mi manca solo lo smart trovo che
credo di aver praticamente già finito
non ci credo non è possibile sono morto
world procaina minchiata sturdà devi
morire
no non l'ho preso perfetto
almeno questo no perché mica impossibile
se non fosse riuscito a fare lo so lo
trovavo emilia mi sarei preoccupato beh
vi trovo che cazzo di prezzo ci va bene
anche volo presso shift ok io non avevo
letto scusa perfetto d'oggi così paolo
ad oggi ed orzo tutte va a fan culo ma
un colpito ho vinto dell'oro ma solo una
persona a cuore come contento no forget
to write si va bene perfetto una stella
la facoltà trio in tutti questi episodi
non mi sono mai mai una volta iscritto
happy wins cioè non c'è io non ho mai
fatto l'account di epic del golden corso
visto che si parla di oro facciamo the
golden card
mio figlio è morto in partenza livello
della madonna che è bello quando un
livello bello lo riconosci da subito che
mi crepe al figlio frecciate terrain
navigation devo navigare nel terreno ma
che cazzo
e vabbè quanto difficile ce l'ho fatta
sono forte passa la prossima challenge
mettimi qualcosa di matematica vedi come
non riesco cazzo prendo b rincorso
ragazzi ce la faccio vai vai vai vai vai
vai non sa che sta ma dai non ci credo
ce l'ho fatta
perfetto 6 con charlene downhill
proviamo questa slot sono andati a casa
mio inchiodato praticamente più piano di
così ok quando andare slot non lo so se
devo andare sloi saranno velocissimo
io sono forte ragazzi potrebbe essere un
problema che non mi ricordo dove sono
morto prima quindi non so era morto qua
era morto qua perfetto mai fatta solo
abbastanza attaccato e mi dicono anzi
non c'avevo con le braccia a voi bazar e
di tagli alza che cosa sono le cose un
azzardo a sono addio le spine ma basta
che vado dritto cioè non è
difficilissimo sto scherzando
però devi stare calmo out e devo andare
adesso vai veloce veloce zio ce l'ho
fatta porca [ __ ] no dai non è vero ma
andate a cagare ero arrivato alla fine
fatemi solo vedere sono arrivato alla
fine tratto la mia pc continua come non
era arrivato alla fine non importa va a
fan culo un livello sono riuscito a non
farlo gli altri si va a vedere già trump
su wall il muro di trump incoming sniper
lo scriva tollo schivato di brutto vai
tra c'è io sono forte fa chi è ma non
c'erano qualcosa di pokemon così a caso
poche morto o meno che cazzo hanno fatto
a casa solo per curiosità è bello ma
vabbè ma è stupendo c'è perché di questo
è il geo dude più bello che abbia mai è
un geode quella roba lì va beh è uno
dove posso lanciare la palla ce la può
che spingerà la palla come se non avessi
mai giocato a pokémon in vita mia we
don't sleep a questa quarta a giocà
pokemon go gò pikachu però son partito
io accetto di sì però mi fai vedere
qualcosa del livello mi devi sparare in
aria
che bello c'è un janger junggar e zheng
arti bello che abbia mai visto nella mia
vita non avere solo solo vedere questo è
per carità ma 4 tong swing
e vabbè vabbè mi sono incastrato signore
mi lasci andare grazie ma devo entrare
che pesano fatti benissimo
si vabbè ma impossibile ma annuncia farò
mai nella vita
nel mondo come faccia ad entrare lì ma
spiegami fatta
non è vero va bene ok che livello della
mi chiamava ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo
facciamo un botto il surf prova a ser
fare sulle bottiglie bello sono riuscito
è per carità non ci credereste mai ho
preso della maionese aveva meno usa
lazio almeno quello io allora giani
bottone non riesco più veloce da porca
miei prodotti e tra tutte mi rimane
sempre la maionese in mano maionese con
frate e ragazze difficilissimo non è
come il bottone che sono lineari diciamo
che se vai bene e curvo come fai a fare
un livello leggero vai veloce non è
possibile
[Musica]
però io inchiostro olio bye bye bye bye
però madonna voto 6 lento ma anche mia
nonna eva benelux e suicidato vai c'è
meno preso vai vai se poi non l'ho
toccato il traguardo maschi gran cazzi
di pene ma vera casuali concluso via
episodio è stato strano ma roba forte
quale come è rimasto quello che direi un
50 mila like solo per questa posizione
molto kamasutra
spero che vi siate 100 ragazzi se mi dai
piaciuto 16 da sotto commento è un mi
piace anche a pacciani facebook come noi
adottata descrizione senza il city ci
vediamo proseguito vabbè si è suicidato
telecomando per colpa di è più visto che
la ragazza